lille a plu à banon est une
consommatrice
métiers au sein du conservatoire des
espaces naturels consiste à gérer et à
organiser donc toutes les actions
scientifiques ce compaq en actions
scientifiques
c'est tout ce qui est protocole de
restauration donc on a des opérations de
lutte contre des espèces exotiques
envahissantes
une fois qu'on a lutté compter peste
donc les espèces exotiques envahissantes
on va replanter des indigènes en
fonction si la régénération naturelle
n'est pas suffisante
et tout cela ça permet en fait de
pouvoir s'approcher d'un état idéal de
ce que c'était la forêt primaire avant
l'arrivée de l'homme car personnellement
je trouve à sion public parce que donc
voilà on a une dizaine de sites en
gestion directe ce qui concerne la lutte
contre les espèces
la récolte de plants le suivi
scientifique la présentation etc
à côté de cette dizaine de sites qu'on
gère en direct
on a enfin je je je fais plus
particulièrement de l'assistance
technique et scientifique auprès des
autres gestionnaires d'espacés naturels
alors qu'est ce que c'est exactement
c'est si un e gestionnaire d'un espace a
besoin d'une compétence particulière
notamment pour un protocole de
restauration ou mettre en place un
chantier de lutte
eh bien il fait appel à mes compétences
et on va travailler je vais travailler
avec eux pour mettre en place le
protocole et mettre en oeuvre l'action
sur le terrain
la nature c'est quelque chose qui me
passionne depuis étant jeune
j'avais l'habitude de regarder tous les
reportages animaliers
ou même sur les forêts en demi que
tropicale et autres à la télé donc du
coup c'est quelque chose qui me
passionne depuis étant jeune j'ai fait
mes études dans ce sens donc j'ai un dea
en écosystèmes terrestres et actions de
l'homme
on étudie vraiment tous les écosystèmes
terrestres notamment et l'influencent de
l'homme là dessus donc comment le gérer
comment intervenir commente pas lié à
l'influencé de l'homme sur les
écosystèmes naturels terrestres et à
côté de ça donc j'ai travaillé aux
seychelles et en inde qui m'a permis
d'en avant de revenir à la réunion
ce qui m'a permis justement de voir les
différentes méthodes de gestion les
différentes problématiques qu'on peut
avoir justement dans la gestion d'un
espace naturel et de pouvoir mettre en
oeuvre
toute cette expérience que j'ai acquis à
la réunion dès mon retour
ce qui me passionne c'est ce que j'adore
c'est de pouvoir être en en forêt anton
et d'armes entre les deux d'oiseaux
entouré de tous ceux cette nature qui
est vraiment à l'origine de
de la vie et je sais pas comment
l'expliquer
bah